we know that being an entrepreneur is no
easy feat and it takes a certain
ecosystem to grow success lots of
strategy money vision of course a lot of
luck at the global startup awards this
year in copenhagen our next guest was
recognized as ecosystem hero of the year
she's from stockholm which per capita is
reportedly has the highest number of
tech unicorns in the world with of
course the exception of silicon valley
so now we're going to welcome hannah
caron and hannah thank you so much for
being here and congrats on the big award
what's the why behind your startup work
what is the reason that you're you're so
invested in this
well thank you so much for having me
it's honestly a big honor that you know
the entire global awards than to be here
as well
um but you know i'm super excited for
the startup ecosystem it's we know that
these technologies we know that the
small startups they actually they have
become mainstream companies and they are
changing the way we live they are
chasing our societies and you know you
get this kind of like a sneak peek
towards future constantly when you're
working with startups so it's very cool
and i'm very devoted to uh to make the
ecosystem even better and the nordic
region even better so yes it's a super
cool job yeah i know your company sting
since uh you were founded in 2002 has
nurtured over 350 tech companies and and
you're in stockholm which i guess is
this tech hub which i didn't realize
really until we we did this story
together can you tell me a little bit
about why you think stockholm has become
such a hub for this work
well um that's very true i think
stockholm is the second you know startup
capital if you think that after silicon
valley that actually uh there has a
nickname stockholm has a nickname called
like the unicorn factory as well so it's
very true that we
we actually
delivered many successful startups but i
think there are you know some key
factors obviously the government has
done a good job there so we had this
called pc package in the 90s that
actually supported families to to get
computers uh so a lot of people became
interested in tech
but also the entire you know people
living here in sweden we are pretty tech
savvy uh we are used to use different
digital services uh we have
hundreds of like exact successful
entrepreneurs that have become like role
models as well uh but also it's kind of
like this
global mentality because we are
stockholm is still a tiny city and
sweden is a tiny market so we have to be
you know global from the day one and
look that uh what can we do to actually
to get the next market and to become
even mainstream so i think that's a good
combination of those kind of like this
scandinavian humbleness
and at the same time we have to think
globally as well and be ready to expand
yeah and when you think about who you
want to work with what is your rubric
for deciding what startup is going to be
a winning idea uh what does that look
like for you how do you determine which
ideas to back and which ones you think
will be successful
well that's it that's a million dollar
question i think about that
it's for sure it's it's hard to predict
but team obviously plays a crucial role
so team is something that we look very
carefully uh we want to see more
diversity we want to see in general we
want to see gender diversity
we want to see like difficult cultures
uh education backgrounds and so forth so
we actually know that the study show was
a more diverse team so the better
performance they actually get so that is
very very important factor
um obviously there has to be a need in
the market so the market have to be
mature enough to start using this kind
of like services or tools
we know for a fact that for instance
climate change is unfortunately still
here and we need solutions we need
desperately both towards energy storages
we need uh consumers need more services
and so forth um so there have to be a
good combination of a stellar team a
need in the market and a certain
innovation level as well yeah and how do
you decide when a startup like how do
you suss out okay this startup is not
only going to address an issue as big as
climate change but it's also going to be
an economic success because i feel like
if you heard that it was going to do a
lot of good for the world it might be
hard to then say oh well actually it's
not going to make a lot of money so we
need to move on you know
yeah it has to it have to actually work
so there has to be you know that there
has to be some kind of
some kind you know bigger in it that
people actually start using this service
for instance that there has to be
some the people let's say that it's an
app that actually attracts us to use
that every day so there has to be
something in it and it's super hard to
sense that it will the company have it
or not
but i think it's important that you go
there go get out of the building as we
say at sting
you start to test your idea like early
on with your potential customers so you
get actually the feedback from them that
is this a good fit or not
and in that sense you gain a lot of like
important knowledge that what should we
do better
and what would you or is this is this
going to fly or not so it's important
actually to go and sell pretty early on
what's something about the startup world
that you think people would be surprised
to learn in terms of the challenges for
ideators i'm curious if you have any you
know dirty secrets to share with us
about the challenges people face
yeah
surprisingly enough although we have a
lot of like capital in the markets uh
it's still a struggle for the startups
to actually get the investment and to
attract investors but it's also super
hard to attract talents
um startups and you know the entire
entrepreneurship is something that it's
bustling it's something that it's uh
people want to become entrepreneurs and
they want to join a startup but at the
same time we know for a fact the
startups they don't offer security
they cannot offer you know high salaries
so they have to be attractive in order
to get the best talents
and there i think it's very important
for them actually to so purpose uh we
know that purpose-driven companies
actually attract more people so i would
actually be
uh i would be very aware of the purpose
of the company and actually highlight
that even more yeah sure what do you
think is the single biggest hurdle that
women in particular face in
entrepreneurship and the startup world
and how could we kind of mitigate that
for female entrepreneurs
yeah it's still
unfortunately we don't see that many
female entrepreneurs
at sting we have a goal that we would
like to see that half of the companies
that are joining our programs would be
female founded
and of sure
the more tech companies and the more
tech savvy we become the less we tend to
see women so it's very important that we
actually bring technology
to everyday life and attract
actually
female and younger women and young girls
to become more interested in this and
for instance we have had an interesting
company called imagi labs that actually
do they they have this app that they
want to attract young girls to start
becoming more interested in coding with
the accessory that they provide at the
same time so it's cool combination that
you are bringing decoding to a young
girl's everyday life that you can you
know you can connect with your your
fellows as well so those kind of
solutions and become you know the
collaboration that we do with schools
that we start educating
our people early on and how important
technology is i think that's very very
important right right it feels like men
are given the space to make mistakes and
get back up again and for women that
first try there's the stakes are so high
yeah it might be and you know that there
is you know studies that show that for
instance when women apply for a job we
want to pre or we want to be able to you
know track all the the the things that
the the company is looking for and we
want
boxes checked so we are a bit more a
kind of security driven and a bit more
that we should get you know more balls
to stay and be there and take those
important tables and that just you know
there yeah yeah absolutely well hannah
really appreciate you joining us and
talking to us about the startup space
and especially how women can break in
and really appreciate that those words
of wisdom